I don't think it's an ethical or moral
dilemma it's more about the constant
guilt that I deal with being a working
mother being somebody who is really torn
on a regular basis about the amount of
time my work takes which I love and the
amount of time I want to spend with my
daughter's I mean it gets easier with
because my oldest daughter is now in
college but I my younger son is still in
high school and then it's really a
constant and juggling act and
emotionally you know I sometimes think
that then they take the baby out and
they put the guilt in so it's something
that every woman I know was a career and
a family is dealing with the fact that
we want to be great at both and and the
fact that we so often feel that we're
not and so the judgments the self
judgments are so draining and I
constantly and talk about that with my
women friends
I think outsiders have advantages in
business I think people who can go
beyond the conventional wisdom people
who don't feel and sort of captured by
the way things have been done and I was
reading recently a book called the
innovators dilemma and and and
Christensen the author writes about how
very successful companies often have a
really hard time with with new
technologies with innovations because
they've been very successful with all
technologies and and the whole essence
of an innovation is that it changes
everything and we see that with
newspapers versus new media and it's
taken the MU a long time to recognize
that consumer habits had shifted that
technologies had changed that terrain
and now some of them are doing a very
good job online like the New York Times
like The Washington Post but in the
process there was a long delay another
the legacy costs are really burdening
them with what they're doing